hi I'm Kevin and I'll be talking about
our paper for itcs 2023 matrix
multiplication via Matrix groups
this is Joint work with Henry Cohn Jonah
blasiak Josh grochow and Chris umans
so
in this talk we'll be discussing the
exponent of Matrix to multiplication
Omega
so this is the smallest real number such
that two n by n matrices can be
multiplied using n to the Omega
arithmetic operations
now it's clear from the
standard algorithm for multiplying
matrices that Omega is at most three
and it's also clear that Omega is at
least two just because we have to Output
N squared numbers
now it was quite surprising is that
strawson showed that this upper bound
this naive upper bound is actually not
optimal
so strassan showed that Omega is less
than 2.81
and since then there's been a flurry of
work on this problem to determine the
best upper bound on Omega and this is
culminated in the bound of Omega is less
than 2.373 roughly of almond and
Williams
now in this talk I'm going to be
discussing a group theoretic approach
to Upper bound Omega
that is capable of capturing all these
the current best algorithms we have
so throughout the talk G will be a
finite group
and the objective of this approach is to
find a large matrix multiplication
tensor inside of the multiplication
tensor for this group G
so what does this mean well
the matrix multiplication tensor is it's
just some polynomial so we'll denote by
n n
and
it's just some trilinear polynomial
namely the sum overall i j k equals one
going from 1 to n of some variable x i j
times some variable y j k times some
variable z k i
so that's the matrix multiplication
tensor and then we have the
multiplication tensor for the group G
which I'll denote by T sub G
and this is just the sum overall pairs
of elements little G and little H in the
group G
of some formal variable x g times some
variable YH times some variable Z
subscript their product GH
so these are just two polynomials
and what does it mean to find a large
matrix multiplication tensor inside of
this T sub G tensor
well it just means we're going to set
some of the variables in t sub G
to be zero
and
and maybe we'll rename the non-zero
variables and in doing so we hope to
obtain a matrix multiplication tensor so
some n n n where n is as big as possible
okay and it turns out uh if you do this
you can actually get upper bounds on
Omega
so very concisely there's this theorem
of Conan numans which says that if we
have three subsets of the group G
such that the equation s times S Prime
inverse times T times T Prime inverse
times U times U Prime inverse equals one
where S and S Prime belong to
big S and similarly for the t's and the
u's
so if this equation only has the trivial
Solutions when s equals S Prime T equals
T Prime and U equals U Prime
then you got some bound on Omega
namely
that the geometric mean of the sizes of
these sets St and U to the power of
Omega
is that most the sum of these numbers d
sub I to the power of Omega and here
these d sub i's are going to be the
dimensions of the irreducible
representations of the group J
okay just some numbers associated with g
and this gives you some upper bound on
Omega
okay
now what's quite cool is that the
current record algorithms all fit into
this framework and this was shown in
work in a work of uh
cone um mans and kleinberg against
segity
now all of the constructions we know in
this framework all look quite similar
all of the constructions that give
non-trivial upper bounds on Omega in
this framework look quite similar so
they take place inside of the group G
being a semi-direct product of
some
big Power of a small cyclic group so
some ZM to the N with the symmetric
group
so here this m is going to be some small
number like eight or nine maybe and N
will be going to Infinity
unfortunately it's known that these
specific kinds of constructions we have
in the these kinds of groups cannot
yield Omega equals two
due to some connections with
additive combinatorics namely the capset
problem
so this raises the question are there
some other families of groups where
maybe we could
find constructions and evade these
barriers
now what what's a good family groups to
consider well one simple observation
is that it turns out that a billion
groups can't give a bound better than
3 on Omega in this framework
so
you might ask what about extremely
non-abelian groups could we
make use of those
so for example
one kind of very non-appealing group
would be
slnfp it turns out so here slnfp is just
the group of n by n
matrices over the field FP
with determinant one
and it turns out that the this group in
some quantitative sense is extremely
non-abelian and a bit more generally we
could consider groups of Lee type so
these are also called Matrix groups
they include
finite analogs of the orthogonal groups
symplectic groups
uh
and so on
and that's what we'll consider in this
talk
so our first result is that actually
you cannot prove Omega equals 2 in this
framework using groups of Lee type
okay so for some Epsilon greater than
zero
no group of lead type can give a bound
on Omega that's better than two plus
Epsilon
and this turns out to be very closely
related to this
phenomenon in groups known as
quasi-randomeness
which we'll now discuss
okay so if we have a group G and we have
three subsets of it a b and c we'll call
them a product free triple if
when you take an A and A B and you
multiply them you never get something in
C okay so a times b equals c has no
Solutions with a at B and C coming from
their respective sets
so as a simple example if we take G to
be the integers mod M under addition
then you can take A and B to both equal
numbers from n over three to two n over
three
and note now that if you take something
in a and you add it to Something in b
you're going to land in the complement
of this set
so you're going to yeah and then the
complement of this set
so therefore if we take C again to equal
this same set a then the equation a plus
b plus c
or a plus b equals c will have no
solution
Okay so
we'll Define this parameter for Group G
now I of G to be the maximum overall
product free triples a b and c
of the the geometric mean of their sizes
so for example
um this this above example shows that
for ZN I I of G is at least n over 3.
okay
so there's a question about this print
about this quantity of the buy and sash
and they asked does is there always a
linear
a linear upper bound or a linear lower
bound on this quantity I of G
so in other words is there some absolute
constant Delta so that if G is at least
Delta times
the size of G for all groups G
and in an influential paper gowers
showed that the answer to this is no
so specifically if we take the group
psl2fp so this is the group of two by
two matrices over FP with determinant
one where we identify two things up to
scaling
we identify two matrices up to scaling
then this this parameter is going to be
bounded by a polynomial on the size of
the group
so IG is going to be at most the size of
G to the power of 8 9.
so there there's no large product free
triple in this group
so this shows that this question of the
buy and sash has a negative answer
okay now let's see how how we can prove
barriers for matrix multiplication if we
assume this result of gowers
okay so the key observation is that the
matrix multiplication tensor
has a large sub cube of zeros
so on the right we can visualize the
this matrix multiplication tensor as
some N squared by N squared by N squared
cube of zeros and ones
um and the entries of the this Cube just
correspond to the coefficients of this
polynomial the matrix multiplication
tensor
and just by definition of the matrix
multiplication tensor if we consider the
consider the sub Cube formed by all
variables
x i j
and y k l where J and K are coming from
different sets so say J is less than n
over 2 and K is greater than n over 2.
and you can take all all of the Z
variables
then there are no monomials in the
matrix multiplication tensor of this
form
so you can think of this as saying that
there's a huge sub cube of zeros in this
matrix multiplication tensor it and
it'll have like volume a quarter of the
volume of the whole matrix
multiplication tensor
okay so therefore if
if
uh within T sub G you could find a huge
matrix multiplication tensor which is
something that's necessary for this
approach to give a good bound on Omega
then this would imply that the tensor
T sub G would also have to have a large
sub cube of zero so it just inherits
this property
but what is a large sub cube of zeros
inside of T sub G well by definition
it's exactly a product free triple
so this would imply that t sub G has a
product free triple
but you know for when G is equal to psl2
we know that there is no product for no
large product free triple
so this shows that
N squared the the side length of this
matrix multiplication tensor
is going to be less than
the size of this group to the power of 8
9 by this fact of gowers
and if you just plug this fact back in
to the
Orem of Conan uman stated earlier then
you'll see that
you cannot beat a bound of 2.25 on Omega
using this group
and it turns out that if you use some
more facts about this group psl2 then
you'll see that this bound actually
approaches three
so these this group is not good for
matrix multiplication
so in our paper we extend this fact to
uh to all groups of lead type
so what was the key property of G that
made this work
well it's it's the thing that made the
result of gowers work namely that inside
of this group so the minimum dimension
of a non trivial irreducible
representation of this group is
extremely large so it grows as a
polynomial in the size of the group
now it turns out that this fact holds
for all groups of lead type
that have bounded rank so here bounded
rank just means that like the dimension
of mate of the matrices is is bounded
so for example in PSL two we were
dealing with two by two matrices but if
you look at PSL 10 then this is still a
group of bounded rank
so for all groups of bounded rank
uh all simple lead groups of bounded
rank we have this theorem
and by using some more facts about the
representation theory of these groups we
can extend this result to
groups of lead type that have unbounded
Rank and that are not necessarily simple
okay so the summary
of this part of the talk is that Matrix
groups cannot yield
Omega equals two in the framework of uh
Conan UMass
so this led to the second part of our
paper where we considered a a different
framework so a continuous framework
so the question is what if you have
constructions of sets in a continuous
group
that satisfy this triple product
property
so think for example we're inside of the
group slnr
okay so we're now dealing with real lead
groups
and one reason for considering this
framework is that it seems easier to
come up with constructions
so for example
we can now use the fact that if you have
a sum of squares of numbers equaling
zero that implies that all those numbers
are zero which is reminiscent of this
triple product property condition we had
earlier
and it turns out it
it's a helpful property
so in the paper we Define the Lee
exponent Omega of G
um as the following so if we have a
group G A Lee Group G of rank r r of G
then the LI exponent of G is going to
equal the infimum over
R of G divided by the average dimension
of M1 M2 and M3
uh minus the dimension of the group G
minus the rank of the group G all
divided by 2. remember this infimum is
taking over all sub manifolds M1 M2 and
M3 that satisfy this triple product
property
all right so just this equation here
only having trivial Solutions is the
property
and the reason why we consider this
quantity is that it's exactly the
analogous bound that you would get on
Omega if you had a construction in the
corresponding finite Matrix Group with
analogous parameters so for example if
instead of having sub manifolds of
dimensions
uh say Dimension M1
M Dimension M2 and dimension M3 if you
had
sets inside of a finite group
of size P to the dimension of M1 P to
the dimension of M2 P to the dimension
of M3
um
then this is exactly the bound to and
get on Omega
so we proved some things about this
quantity we show that just like in the
finite case
avilian groups
do not have Lee exponents
less than three the Lee exponent of any
abilian group is equal to three
unlike
the finite setting where we had this
barrier from quasi-randomness we don't
know a barrier to obtaining Lee exponent
2 inside of inside of Matrix groups
at the same time we we don't know of an
upper bound
on on the Lee exponent of a group that's
better than three
so something we show is that
um
if you take
large powers of the group slnr
then the Lee exponent of this this
resulting group is going to be bounded
by three plus little low
of 1 where this little o of one is going
to go to zero as M grows
and in for this theorem the sub
manifolds that we use are
uh the m-fold power of this special
orthogonal group
and m-fold power of the upper uni
triangular group
and this funny group it's going to be a
subgroup of the
lower triangular matrices so it's going
to be tuples
M tuples of lower triangular matrices
such that when you take the product of
all of the entries in position one one
in such a tuple you've got one and when
you take a product of all elements and
entry 2 2 and such a tuple you get one
and and so on
so it turns out that these sub manifolds
will satisfy the triple product property
condition
up to some small failure which we can
take care of
okay so this leaves open many questions
so one question is can we prove any
further restrictions on
the dimensions of an irreducible
representation
on the of the irreducible
representations of a group if they could
give Omega equals 2. so we know a
billion groups can't give Omega equals
two
so all the dimension Europe Dimensions
can't equal one we also know that
the
uh first non-trivial era cannot be large
so that's some other condition but is
there more we could say
and a related question is can we either
prove barriers for or come up with
constructions in the group say psl2 FP
to the power of M where m is large
[Music]
um
so our barriers don't apply to this
so
yeah
and finally so we have this continuous
framework but it's not immediately clear
how you if you can or how you can
get
algorithms get actual algorithms for
matrix multiplication from constructions
in these groups
so that is to say is the actual exponent
of matrix multiplication Omega
bounded by this quantity the Lee
exponent
of some lead Group G
uh
and finally can you prove a bound on the
we exponent of any group that is better
than three
all right so thank you
and here are the references